[Musique]
la raison d'être de ce musée c'est
l'héritage de deux siècles d'histoire et
la plupart des instruments scientifiques
que l'on présente dans ce musée c'était
des instruments qui servait aux travaux
pratiques des élèves et ce sont aussi
des instruments qui provenaient des
laboratoires de l'école polytechnique
donc au départ ces instruments nous
n'avait pas vocation à être exposée dans
un musée il avait pour vocation de
servir à faire la science et donc du
fait de l'histoire ils se sont retrouvés
donc dans les collections de la
bibliothèque et ce qui manquait c'était
un lieu pour les exposer donc maintenant
le public a vraiment la possibilité de
venir découvrir ces instruments et au
travers de ces instruments découvrir
l'histoire de l'école polytechnique donc
qui existent je rappelle depuis 1794 et
dès l'origine de cette école
il y avait comme objectif de donner donc
aux élèves aussi bien des cours
théoriques que des cours pratiques donc
dans des laboratoires à la pointe des
avancées scientifiques de cette époque
là
vous trouverez dans ce musée des
instruments et des documents qui sont
antérieurs à la création de l'école
polytechnique donc antérieurs à 1794
c'est assez curieux mais c'est pour une
raison qui est assez simple finalement
c'est que au moment où l'école est créée
en 1794 il faut donc réunir les
instruments qui seront localisés dans
les différents laboratoires et donc on
va aller chercher ces instruments dans
ce qu'on appelle les dépôts
révolutionnaire qui sont les dépôts où
l'on a réuni les différentes collections
qui proviennent des institutions royal
qui ont été supprimés par la révolution
qui proviennent des collections privées
de nobles par exemple qui ont été
confisqués et donc dans ses collections
ses dépôts nationaux on trouve donc des
instruments et des ouvrages qui remonte
bien avant la révolution
le musée est gratuit et il est ouvert
donc tous les jours de la semaine du
lundi au vendredi de 9 heures à 17
heures sauf pendant les vacances
scolaires ou le musée donc est ouvert de
10h à 16h
[Musique]